[Music]
it's a day that ends with y so you know
what that means
someone on reddit thinks they know
what'll happen in the next avengers
movie
if you want to ensure that the official
trailer reveal has a zero percent chance
of being spoiled click away now
for those of you who are still here
let's get started in the lead-up to the
launch of avengers 4
on may 3 2019 internet gossip and rumors
spread faster than spider-man decides to
ditch school to fight space aliens
but even amid the sea of speculation
directors joe and anthony russo have all
but super glued their mouth shut in
efforts to speak as little as possible
about the movie
even going so far as to not reveal the
film's official title
even though we're only nine months out
from the movie's release but if the
latest internet post to gain traction is
to be believed
all that effort may have been in vain
the latest bit of avengers 4 buzz
is that the title and trailer
description has reportedly leaked online
months ahead of time
posted subsequently deleted and later
re-shared by several users on reddit
yes if this post is accurate marvel
studios efforts that secrecy would seem
to have been an utter failure
fortunately for them the whole thing
sounds way way too bonkers to actually
be real
the description includes all kinds of
exciting dramatic details
that you'd expect to see in the infinity
war follow-ups trailer
we've got a shot of thanos's damaged
infinity gauntlet in a field on the farm
planet
we've got robert downey jr speaking in
voice over saying we were destined to
lose
we've even got quote an epic music score
you know as opposed to a trailer with a
non-epic music score
like this
[Applause]
but those aren't the only details that
sound plausible we've got mbaku sitting
on the throne in wakanda
taking over for t'challa while he's
nothing more than a pile of dirty leaves
we've got thor and valkyrie hanging out
on a cruise ship the kind of space
vessel marvel fans should expect to know
pretty well
after captain marvel hits in march of
2019 we've got hawkeye and full ronin
gear in japan
hanging out with the yakuza so far so
possible so this description has all the
general signifiers you'd expect out of a
trailer for the dramatic and incredible
superhero sequel
but there are also a few other details
in the supposed trailer description that
seemed to throw a whole lot of water on
the idea that it's real
what kinds of details well how about the
part of the description where a quote
rocket and nebula are modifying some new
weapons in the lab
rocket says when can we try this bad boy
out they both smile at each other and
fist bump
you heard right according to this post
rocket and nebula
fist bump that's gross that's not the
only head scratcher in here
the description says that after the
movie's title is revealed to be avengers
annihilation
we'll get a shot of black widow captain
america and the hulk training at a new
shield facility
steve notices that hulk has been
training non-stop as of late
so he asks why hulk responds in banner's
normal voice with my rematch is coming
real
soon i can feel it
those details among others have left the
commenters on reddit to conclude that
the post is pretty far from legit
highlights of other redditors reactions
include quote this is such utterly trash
fanfiction i can't believe anyone
thought it was real
and sounds like something goku would say
oh wow
that guy's awesome and while the
addition of goku to avengers 4 would
probably make the movie about a thousand
times more amazing
it's hard not to agree that some of the
details listed in the description
do seem a little difficult to believe so
is this description possibly the real
deal
or the product of one fan's imagination
after spending months reading rumors and
theories on the internet
either way in the absence of official
trailers or details from marvel studios
random reddit threads are pretty much
all fans have to go on
the hype for avengers 4 is crazy high
and fans are getting tired of waiting
for the movie to hit already
hopefully we'll get a glimpse of the
official trailer soon and we can know
the truth for sure
in the meantime let's all just get
serious for a second
this is probably what the next avengers
trailer is going to be like
for real
[Music]
you